gabriel boric 35 años ya un paso de ese
el presidente más joven de la historia
de chile no le tenga la me dio miedo a
la juventud para cambiar este país
porque también
bebemos de la experiencia de quienes
lucharon antes que nosotros un discurso
que busca a los jóvenes que participaron
en el estallido social de 2019 en
rebeldía contra el conocido como milagro
económico de chile chile fue la cuna el
neoliberalismo también será tu compañero
precisamente por it se dio a conocer
como líder estudiantil en 2011 esto le
permitió saltar a la política en 2014
cuando fue escogido diputado de
magallanes la zona más austral y
olvidada de chile de donde es oriundo
su partido convergencia social forma
parte de la coalición frente amplio
junto al partido comunista de ganar se
convertiría en el presidente más a la
izquierda en chile desde salvador
allende derrocado por un golpe de estado
en 1973
boris busca enterrar a la dictadura
militar de augusto pinochet y su
constitución de 1980 representando a una
nueva generación que ha dejado atrás la
histórica centroizquierda de la
concertación e incluso su última
presidenta michelle bachelet pidió votar
por boris nueva lo mismo entonces por
qué candidato se vota
bueno una búsqueda de centro que se suma
a sus críticas a los gobiernos de
venezuela y nicaragua pero desde la
oposición no se fían y condenan su
reunión en españa con uno de los
asesinos del diputado derechista jaime
guzmán
moritz promete diálogo y recuerda el 15
de noviembre de 2019 cuando fue artífice
del acuerdo que derivó en el actual
proceso constituyente esto le valió
críticas internas en su coalición
mientras sin corbata y arremangado busca
ser el presidente de la nueva
constitución